The faces are just killing me, man. The faces are killing me,
Hutch. >> I don't ask for much, man. Just don't straw man
the [__] out of me. >> You're totally Why can't
you just admit you got destroyed here? Nothing Hutch says fixes
this. Hutch just copes. He knows he got destroyed here. Shut
up. >> Hutch hatred is is is quite intense, but he's just
wrong about >> He's coping more. >> these liberals
>> This is insane. This is just him coping,
All right, without further ado, I think we should have enough
people in at this point that we could go over to the Hutch >> Um
let's just start with the Justical
I I still don't know if I'm saying that right, by the way. Okay.
Hutch exposed
the Hasan [__] lie is absurd. And then on the thumbnail,
it says he's wrecked with text that says gaslighting {question
mark}. >> But actually [laughter] >> It's It's so
what? It's so over the top.
get into it. >> But I'm looking at a different conversation
that should be had. I want like a meta discussion on the concept
of liberal democracy and whether it's capable of acting quickly
enough, of being agile enough to deal with modern concerns. I
want that conversation to be had more and more and more, and
anything I can talk about that lets me hammer that point home.
Dude, the faces already. The faces. >> But I do not think
the current liberal the the
the general framework of the liberal democracy right now is effective
in the world moving this fast, corporations moving this fast,
okay?
I need I need that conversation to be had. And right now we're
seeing people who are basically arguing for a form of
And I want them to do better. Because I
That's a fascist talking point.
Is it? Am I Am I I fascism when I say I'm not sure that an improvement
to democracy. I mean, I guess like I do understand how that is
something that the like Andreessen types would be saying. I do
get that. Like obviously you'd have to be very careful about
what you do here to to move in any sort of illiberal
>> What is his Does anyone know his politics? So what does
J. Stack What kind of system does he want? Does he
>> Why Why do you The system I want is liberal democracy.
That's the system I want.
That's literally the system I want was liberal democracy.
But now I'm starting to see limitations.
You know what I'm saying? So that's my problem is I see limitations.
But when he asks like what my politics are, what system I want
When he asked that, I think what he's asking and I I've seen
this as a pattern in Hutch a lot is he's looking for a way to
short circuit any conversation. He's looking for a way to dismiss
and he's looking for any hook he could possibly
to stop engaging mentally. We'll go cuz I'll let more of his
responses come through, but I think that's really what he's looking
for is like oh this guy is a this guy is a communist, this guy
is a socialist. Well, come up with solve the whole system or
else don't talk to me. We should run the gamut from modest changes
to extreme changes and go through what what we could possibly
change and see what's going to work or argue about what's going
to work.
You know what I'm saying? But he just doesn't want to I find
that weird that he's like what's his beliefs instead of engaging
with this idea that I just presented that maybe liberal democracy
is having an issue keeping up with the current rate of change
in technology.
He just starts going and talking about what my politics are.
Now I I understand if he just says oh I don't want to go to fascism
or communism full blow. Yeah, I
I agree. >> authoritarian leftist government? Does he want
dictatorship? Does he want something more technocratic? Like
what is he Is he a tankie?
>> The problem with the technocracy, cuz the the technocracy
is probably one of the solutions here. The problem with the technocracy
is that
if the issue is the people
who are technically apt or knowledgeable have too much power
right now, and I think it's imbalanced it's imbalanced
and they're slowly collecting more and more power, power, wealth,
all of these things. And I'm not sure how the technocracy actually
helps. Like I'm not sure it gets better with a technocracy,
>> Is he a tankie? The thing is, when we're evaluating
the merits of liberal democracy in the modern era,
we've already tried
Like I say we, like as a species, we've already tried a lot of
other kinds of systems, and so far
liberal democracy is the best system, I would say by far.
If you want to maximize
>> So, I guess
what I'm proposing for every other point in human history,
human capital has been the the most scarce and best resource
you could have. Like human capital trumps everything, and I think
we're entering an age where that will no longer be true.
And so I don't know how that how things break. And it's concerning
to me that things seem to be breaking. Like we're we're trending
towards things getting worse and worse. I don't know if we're
ever going to see the value of of just general labor, skilled
unskilled both. I don't know if we're ever going to see the trends
reverse on that and go back towards being worth more.
And so what do we do when that happens? Cuz the whole point of
the liberal democracy is when you keep every single person in
the society happy and and capable of like economic mobility and
all of this, then you maximize egalitarianism
and everything works. But if you don't have that that guarantee
that human capital will always be required and elite human capital
will always move humanity forward, or will always be the solution
to all of humanity's problems. Like, if it starts to become more
Like, maybe it's always elite human capital, but that that tiny
elite gets like very, very, very small. The value of labor is
just factually decreasing. So, you either need to do something
in terms of the law, like setting that
but then that's not really that's not capitalism, that's not
you know, for an open marketplace.
But, I'm not advocating for any specific change. It's just like,
"Hey, I'm basically pointing at an iceberg, but I don't know
how to move the ship." I don't know how to move the ship. I see
the iceberg. I want to talk about how we avoid the iceberg.
>> There's been no other system quite like it throughout
the span of human history.
It's unquestionably
led to the best outcomes.
So, is he trying to go back to a system that another country
has already tried that he thinks would be better?
>> His politics endlessly critiquing power with no real
strategy to gain it. Um he doesn't think liberal democracy can
deal with the challenges of misinformation and automation.
He doesn't really have prescriptions.
Well, listen, Jay Stack, if you're watching this
in the future, this is Hutch from the
>> I mean, I could easily like spitball some prescriptions.
I'm just saying that it seems like we have to start having that
conversation, and the longer we get stuck on other conversations,
the more we're not having that conversation, which is very
>> And I just want I want to know what is
prescription? Like, what kind of system do you think we should
be going for? Cuz it's not enough to just have a conversation
questioning liberal
He's saying that >> is. Yes, it is. There's a meteor coming
for Earth, and it's just like, "Well, listen, we've everything's
always been good. Why are you trying to change things?" Cuz there's
a meteor, man.
There's a literal meteor over there. It's coming for us. We got
to do something. And I'm not even saying you got to go I'm not
like advocating, you know, overthrowing the system, blowing anything
up, nothing like that. I'm saying talk about the meteor.
What do you do? Cuz all these trends I don't even hear anybody
talking about how to reverse these trends beyond taxation. And
it just feels like taxation goes to the capital flight argument
and that gets very spooky very >> He wants there to be
a meta discussion about like can liberal democracy really
keep up with how rapidly technology is evolving and automation
and da da da da da da. Like what are you suggesting?
He doesn't have political conviction. You're just being too generous
by thinking he cares.
Well, let's challenge him to be better. >> None of these
people are even engaging with the argument and I'm being told
I don't have conviction.
Very interesting.
You don't have conviction. Well, I'm responding to arguments.
>> Jay Stalk, if you're watching this in the future, okay?
This is me from the past. This is me from 9:27 a.m.
on April 24th.
>> It's not enough to just talk endlessly about problems.
You need to be able to have some kind of a sense of what kind
of solutions you think would be best. And so I want to know
>> Yeah, I don't want to just endlessly talk about problems.
I think going for people who are for far more progressive taxation
is a good way to do this because honestly, if you start taxing
these people if you if you force something to change, then maybe
we get to a better solution, right? So I'm fine with going for
people who are in favor of more progressive taxation.
That would be like a short-term thing. So trying to go to more
progressive taxation, trying to move towards a sovereign wealth
fund would be like medium term.
So you could start taking on some of these corporations and and
when you're taxing them, if you have a sovereign wealth fund,
then it's a simple matter of transferring shares, right? And
you come up with some system for for companies to consistently
transfer shares and and that deals with the hopefully in some
way deals with the taxation problem we have where it's only based
on revenue or income and not based on increased valuation.
That would be the the prescription would be like an increased
taxation.
Right? Some way of taxing, probably fixing the issue where we
have taxing on revenue or income instead of like wealth generation,
and then people could just borrow money against their wealth
generation, what their wealth growth like their growth in whatever
their their uh what would you say? Their assets are. And they
just generate money and they essentially are not
Those would be short-term, medium-term solutions. But again,
those things would have have downsides, but to me, you start
with those things, right? Cuz realistically, the technology thing's
a
But what the biggest problem is is the devaluation of labor.
As if AI becomes far more capable than it is now, which I feel
like it's it's going to do. At least in terms of white-collar
work, I think it is going to become more
as it eliminates white-collar jobs, you're going to have like
no demand for new work.
And people are basically going to
I like I don't know. What do you think
if you lose 20% of white-collar jobs in
within the next 3 years, let's say?
Like what happens? Those are all the educated jobs. >> There's
no evolving. It's literally just another vector for them to attack
>> Hutch, if you're watching this,
did you just If your chat is referencing Destiny instead of talking
about whatever I'm saying, could you just say, "Wait, are you
going to address what's being said? Or are you going to constantly
bring up Destiny instead of Like I understand I will mention
Destiny sometimes in that you seem to share a lot of overlap
in politics with him.
If you need me to not do that, I cannot do that. But my god,
please don't relate my ideas or what I think about to that. It's
just annoying.
>> He's just going to say cut off Israel. No, I'm serious.
Does he literally not
It can't be I think maybe you guys are being too mean to him.
There's no way he he's never stated any kind of
preference for what sort of system we should have.
>> The preference is liberal democracy.
I'm seeing shortcomings in my
I don't think there's a system change that I see. I don't think
there's a prescribed system such as I've seen it that I'm happy
with that either.
>> Surely he's not over here saying
I'm just asking questions and just like leaving it there.
>> I'm going to speed up a little >> that the current
liberal like structure of the economy and is something that can
be maintained or should be maintained forever. Because I don't
know what it means. I like I don't know what the economy or or
markets like I don't know what these concepts mean if we get
to a point where we can automate literally 90% of
the current labor market. Uh I don't know what that looks like.
What is what does capitalism mean? What does what does supply
and demand mean? Like what >> That's what I'm saying is
that conversation needs to be had. That conversation is happening.
Like that is happening right now. And basically if you get to
the
you have the current system the current
of the economy and people are able to gain enough assets enough
like ability to make stuff that they become insulated and
like fiefdoms in and of themselves. Like Peter Thiel builds the
the floating island of doom that can't really be attacked or
assailed in any way. Okay?
I I feels like there are real issues like akin to that. That's
probably not realistic like very very soon. >> The value
of labor will keep decreasing.
wealth gap will keep increasing. And if nothing changes if we
have our current layout of the economy and how we think of liberty
then there will be no moral basis by by you can possibly redistribute
that wealth. And it seems like the way Congress works right now
and the way like with how divided people are, people will never
get on the same page to actually address that problem.
And it feels like it feels counterintuitive, but we're almost
it's almost at the point where we're like talking about Trump
a lot. And I don't know even know if that's like the most existential
threat to the world at this point, which is shocking given that
I do think he's obviously doing the most harm in the world by
orders of magnitude over any other human being right now. Like
what do what do >> wages mean?
What does work mean? What if we can get to a place where 90%
of things are automated? I don't know what that looks like. It
It's going to look very different from what we got going on right
now.
>> Okay, but what if you get there and it is the current
layout?
What if you What if you get there and it's basically laid out
the exact way it is right now?
What changes? What like what
What are you going to do? How do you
How do you start like taking care of
The system is just set up now. The quality of life of everybody
in America is slowly being leached away. And there is nobody
who's going, "Hey, we need to stop that. That needs to stop.
That's like our number one thing. We need to stop that right
now." >> But I don't know what that means. I like I have
no idea what does that mean for government if we can do something
like that? Ironically, I think AI can bring about their communist
utopia.
Or I shouldn't say AI, but like
I I ironically I think like full
will get them closer to their communist utopia than uh
doing this larpy revolutionary,
which I don't know if he's doing that. >> I even got to
tell you that I want Hasan to like win or his candidates to win.
In fact, I think they will largely lose. I and the framing Hutch
is setting up is, well, if they do really badly, that shows that
there's no appetite for this. That is not true. Okay? That is
not true. Do not let them gaslight you on this. >> It's
kind of necessarily true. It doesn't mean that there will never
be an appetite for it in the future, but in the short term, if
his candidates get blown out throughout this cycle, it means
that there's not an appetite for his kind of politics right now.
That is kind of necessarily true. >> No indication that
if you lose badly in any of these No, it's not. So much of politics
has nothing to do with actual personal like it has nothing to
do with policies. It's not an aversion to policy that people
are voting against these people for. It's the like network around
them. It is that they don't have the endorsements that they that
they haven't been around for a long time. It's so much more than
just these straight-up policies. This is like so it's so
it's like diluted, right? To think it's just about the politics,
the the policies themselves, it's not. And obviously it's on
the rise. Like all you have to look at is Obama wanting to be
photographed, be at a photo op with with Zohran Mamdani. You
look at that, that is your window into how things are shifting.
Why did Obama do that?
Right? You just need to think about that. Why did he want that?
Why did he think that was important? Why did he think that is
something he should do?
It's obviously the way things are shifting, and while there may
not be an appetite for some of those candidates right now, I
do think it's going to keep growing. These elections
Okay, look at the spending. Look at the ad buys that are going
to go into these elections to prevent these primary candidates
from being successful because they are terrified of this kind
of narrative. They're totally terrified. >> Do we have
[__] or Dosvedanya in the chat? Um >> Engage.
Engage. Engage. >> You you have high-profile races that
attract a lot of donors.
That's true. A lot of a lot of money >> What makes it a
high-profile race that attracts a lot of donors, Hutch? >> Money
gets spent in these primary contests to stop
>> It seems to me like in these primary contests, it becomes
like a high donor race when there is a far left candidate who
is running against some more liberal
And and that could be far left in terms of economic policy, could
be far left or or like anti-Zionist if there's an anti-Zionist
candidate. I've seen both of these cases happen where that becomes
a high-profile race almost immediately. >> progressive
candidates from winning.
But the norm is just, you know, most races are not attracting
like high-level amounts of donors.
And so it's just the case
>> Is there a race where somebody who is aligned with let's
say El-Sayed or
or Hassan
Is there a Is there a race where somebody like that is running
and that is not attracting a donations, a outside scrutiny or
outside
Can we name Can we name that case?
Cuz I think that is explicitly the exact case where it happens.
>> Progressive candidates are getting
like really blown out in races that are just happening that don't
have >> Wait, but like progressive candidates who never
had a shot?
Like I admit, there might be like a DSA candidate running in
some district in Texas who gets 0.2% of the vote.
But that's the whole point. He's like those politics don't really
get a fair shake. Like nobody in Texas is voting for a socialist
like an an avowed socialist in any way. I agree with that.
I'm not saying that the politics work on every single level,
but there's multiple reasons why why just straight up the politics
don't work, right? You would need some sort of some sort of buy-in
from some organized group to get any one of these candidates
off the ground somewhere. Obviously, you're going to start in
places where you have a chance at winning. Somewhere like Michigan,
somewhere like New York, right? You're not going to immediately
go to the most purple districts or even red districts to try
to get them elected there. >> have a lot of national attention
and like ad spending.
So the idea that you can find high-profile races where a lot
of money is being spent to boost the, you know, non-progressive
candidate in the primaries. That's not evidence that
people are horrified of like some big >> So, even if you
lose that
what is it evidence of? What What is it evidence of? The indication
that your politics is working is a flood of money against you.
That's the indication. That's your primary indicator, your North
Star. The more money they're spending against you in terms of
primaries, that is showing that you are resonating with people
and it scares them. It terrifies them. They're spending more
and more and more money to try to make up that gap that they
can How is this even arguable? I'm just saying something that's
like obviously
How is anyone going to argue against
So, never let people tell you that the reason the whole reason
that you're like, oh, that this is the litmus test right now,
or sorry, that this is the test. This will tell us. This is the
experiment and we'll know after this. No, you won't know after
this. You won't >> It would be scary if people were spending
tremendous amounts, like
were spending tremendous amounts of money in races all over the
country.
>> That No, there's only a handful of like viable candidates.
It's obviously like a new movement that's getting like bootstrapped
and they're pulling up new candidates all over the country, right?
You don't have to spend money all over the country because the
the DSA candidate who's going to get 0.1% of the primary vote
in Texas doesn't need money spent against them. Do you know how
you make money? It's by being careful in how you spend your >> Then
it would be kind of scary.
>> If your if your perspective is that the the current
progressive wing of the Democratic Party are not to be trusted
if we give them power, it would lead to bad outcomes. If you're
afraid of them in that kind of way,
then the only time you're going to be afraid afraid is if if
you're forced to spend a lot of money in really competitive districts.
All right? This is This is years long. This is a years long thing.
This is not this cycle. This is not these midterms. It's not
even the next presidential
Don't stop. Don't get particularly intelligent hutch chatter
right here. Um Nazi Germany's politics was working because the
entire world spent billions fighting against their ideology.
Thanks, Jay Stock. Yeah, those are the same. That's That's very
close. Those are very close things. All right. Okay, this is
we're going on to the next time stamp here. This is the next
one. >> Right now, they seem
very emboldened in a way that I don't think I've ever seen. Um
I don't think that their evaluation of the current moment is
grounded in reality. Like they do seem to think that there is
a massive kind of
of their kind of politics all over the country, and they selectively
pick like >> The massive surge of their kind of politics
is seen in Donald Trump winning an election in 2024
after trying
the faces are just killing me, man. The faces are killing me,
Hutch. Hutch understands that these faces, like I'm fine with
you I'm more or less fine with him using them against me, but
he he has to understand that when he uses these faces against
his friends, like he uses this same face when he's talking to
like Pisco and stuff, right? This is the face you make when you're
like, this guy's a that I'm talking to. That's what you're signaling
to your audience. Just He I hope he realizes that.
>> Donald Trump winning in 2024
was a sign that the far left's politics are ascending right now.
How do
>> that people are
So, I would say this is basically evident in the fact that people
are upset. They don't know what how they they have no concept
of how to fix their problems, right? People are generally upset,
and they're willing to vote for somebody who is essentially like
a middle finger to anything logical or reasonable
because of that. And the far left is trying to talk about this
and those problems as well. And I feel like a lot of the times,
when I listen to people who are of a more liberal persuasion,
particularly IRI or or Hutch, it seems like they're basically
trying to explain away people's problems. They're trying to explain
why your problems aren't real
Right? Like they're they're fake problems. Actually, the economy
isn't that bad. You just ordered DoorDash too much. You're trying
to signal to people about what you're going to do based on some
level of polling and not based on some long-term
commitment to these values, like Kamala did. Right? She wasn't
like long-term committed to some sort of centrist value. She
was the most progressive voting senator in the Senate when she
was a senator, right? She was She had the most progressive voting
record. So, when she pivots back to the center, it's not even
credible. People don't even take it seriously, right? That's
why everybody can dismiss her. You're like the the turbo progressive,
the uber progressive. Why would we take this seriously when you
pivot towards the center? That doesn't mean anything. >> What
is that?
Excuse me? Is he conflating populism with like far left politics?
>> and to steal the 2020 election.
That's the massive surge in their politics. They are just trying
to say that you guys are the party of of >> I I hate populism.
I hate populism. I hate populism. I hate it. >> Like uh
what is it? Um a slow and steady decline? You guys are the party
of like just basically manage it rearranging deck chairs on the
Titanic. You guys are the party of
And that even if they're lying, the Republicans are trying to
paint like some vision on how things could change. And you're
just like, "No, things are really good." But nobody thinks things
are really good. And if you're going to run on a thing on a on
a platform of, "Well, weren't things great under Biden? And we'll
go back to like just, you know, slow incremental change." >> I
would definitely not frame a campaign along these lines.
I don't ask for much, man. Just don't straw man the [__]
out of me. Please. You know like >> Wait, how is he framing
a campaign?
Cuz I swear to God anytime he's asked about Biden, it's Biden
is the most consequential
and effective president of my lifetime. Everything about his
his presidency was amazing.
What do you mean?
How am I inaccurate? How am I strawmanning? How am I making something
Tell me how Biden failed if you want to say that I'm strawmanning
you when I say you want to go back to what Biden was doing. Where
Where am I Where am I strawmanning you? >> I I think that's
fair. Like just don't strawman the
out of me, you know. Don't pull poop out of me by strawmanning
me. Constantly strawmanning me. I would never in a thousand years
recommend that the 2028 Dem nominee run on, "Hey guys, everything
was actually really good under Biden. You just didn't realize
it. So let's >> Okay, Hutch, what do you talk about?
Hutch, what do you talk about? You You constantly tell me Biden's
the most effective president ever. That he was he was great.
He was the
You can't say that and then not say that more Biden would be
good.
What are you What are you excited to run >> Let's go back
to that. I would never run on that kind of messaging.
Jack with $10, this guy has the political analysis of a penguin.
Also, he used to be an anti-populism guy yes less than a year
ago. Wait, what?
>> I I don't like right-wing populism.
But unfortunately, at this point, it seems like at some level
you have to fight fire with fire. Right? So rhetoric is important.
You should have the policies to back rhetoric, but rhetoric is
important.
And unfortunately, I also see the Dude,
the ContraPoints tweet I retweeted yesterday was really funny.
Apparently, people don't find my political message inspiring.
Might need to workshop this. Take your Zoloft and vote for neoliberalism
before things get even worse. I'm like, that is what it is, right?
That is the argument. Is literally take your meds, vote for vote
for the managed decline because you have no idea how much worse
it'll get outside of the managed decline. The managed decline
is the best you'll ever get.
That's like unironically and I as long as you're willing to own
that, like ContraPoints is, I'm like, "Okay."
Like, at least you own it. But, these people will try to have
the aspirational lane as well. And I'm like, "Dude, you don't
believe that. You have to believe you You can't do both at the
same time. You can't be like, 'Okay, this these more incremental
policies that barely shift anything are the way to go.'
And also, it's not that bad, right?"
Okay, we keep going. >> true? Give me evidence of that.
Show me a clip of him being anti-populist. This guy's all over
the place, man. Can't relate. I'm still the I'm still the same
harm reduction lib I've been for the last
>> Steady, repetitive decline, and we'll be all good, guys.
You're not going to talk about any of the big issues, any of
these massive icebergs facing your country and broadly the planet.
>> president is important >> talk about any of that.
We're just going to be like, "Guys, listen. If we just build
like 5% more housing, we really solve a lot of problems." >> I
would not I would definitely not run on this, for the record.
I don't Why do I need to even
>> Oh, what? Cool.
What is Hutch running on? What policy is Hutch running on?
Cuz maybe I just never hear it. I hear a ton about how Hassan
can't be in the
I hear a ton about how you can't punish Trump for the crimes
that like basically those investigations would be poisoned because
of bias and that that would be really bad for liberalism liberalism
overall. I don't hear about the solutions, the the policy Hutch
really likes. What's Hutch's most aspirational favorite policy
that he's advocating for and that he supports every politician
that's in favor of or that is in favor of it. This leave. Would
love to know. I don't think I don't think anybody feels that
way. And I'm not saying burn it down, but you got to actually
talk about what's
Why unemployment continues to rise, why the economy is in the
[__] why it's not likely that it will recover in
the near
>> Who's that voice? >> Somebody has to talk about
it, right? Surely we can't all enter this totally derealized
state with this the state where nothing is real, nothing >> The
The Democrats are already doing this, you guys. They're already
running
on the economy and talking about
the myriad ways that Donald Trump is this economy. They're already
running on that, right?
>> Yeah, that's the derealization. It's only Donald Trump.
Donald Trump is us on the economy.
>> That's not true.
The macro
state of the the the broad
thousand-foot view of the economy is going badly for every person
for for every voter. The average voter is them in the ass, and
it will not matter whether it's Democrats or Republicans. You
need to talk about that trend.
And how you're going to reverse that
And when you refuse to acknowledge that trend and the fact that
people's material reality got significantly worse when Joe Biden
was president,
then you're going to keep losing because you seem like you're
disconnected from the average person. Like I I don't know how
else to say That is going to be it every time. Acknowledge the
broad trend. It is not just Trump. Do not stop trying to just
say it's Trump. Talk about the world. Talk about how the world
is changing, and that's a challenge. Like basically saying, "No,
things are great, aren't they?" as they continuously
>> What Democrats are doing this? Like what Democrats are
running on this? Where did >> Again, maybe this just wasn't
clear for Hodge. So now it is clear, right? Now it is. I'm saying
that the state of the economy that you will never see significant
gains in America like
you know, significant return to this level of standard of living,
it just will not happen. We'll never be back at the 2016 standard
of living in like this
This paradigm, such as it is, when we have the current tax system,
when when a lot of the things are the same, nothing can change.
Absolutely nothing can change. Anybody who tells you that they
can change your economic reality, given the like how the liberal
democracy, this capitalist liberal democracy is set up right
now, it can't change. It is totally economically infeasible for
it to change. Like it doesn't make sense. It would require just
essentially charity from
>> Where does he get this information? What is What is
up with these Canadians?
If you're going to cover American
as a Canadian, okay, that's fine. But like what are you talking
about? Like
what Democrats are running on, you know, actually everything's
fine, you guys just don't realize it yet. Who's doing this? What
the [__] are you talking
>> Everything's fine is essentially evident
when you will not when you when you try to like ideologically
purity test out the people who are arguing things aren't fine,
regardless of which party is in charge. That's like your evidence
right
>> I I agree. Don't do that. That's silly. >> I think
there's still some hope. Not a not a big hope. I'm I'm basically
like
a small percentage. That like some liberal change could be made.
But if you're not willing to talk about the problems, you're
never going to gradually fix the problems.
You have to be able to You have to be able to discuss what the
problems are for you to be able to fix them. >> I think
I understand what's going on here. Uh I think he thinks the problem
>> He's I I really hope he understands what's going on
here. I really hope so. >> He's going to frame the problems
in a within a populist framework. And so he the the things that
he identifies as
are not necessarily the same things that, you know, normie Democrats
are identifying as problems.
And therefore, because the normie Democrats are not ex >> That
that is what I'm saying is when they are refusing to identify
the problems or saying everything's fine. >> framework
and and discussing his problems and centering his problems as
being like the main problems.
In his mind he's like, "They never talk about the problems."
It's like, "Well, they do. They just don't necessarily agree
with you on what the problems are and what the best solutions
for those problems are."
>> Yeah, they just don't talk about the most important
things very often. Yep. We're done with that timestamp. We're
on to the next one. What is it? Dude, there's um >> Oh
man, what is the Is it an MLK saying? "Those who make peace impossible
make violence inevitable." Those who make equality impossible
make violence inevitable. That if things are broken, things aren't
working and you refuse to acknowledge that or make or even hint
towards change. If things are truly broken, you make some kind
of like violence, some kind of revolutionary ideas inevitable.
I believe that. That you have to start talking about this stuff.
You got to. Even if it's a meta conversation about like, "Hey,
maybe
cuz technology is such a big thing." I think if you start with
the meta conversation, which a lot of people have had this, but
it seems to have disappeared. "Hey, we're not updating fast enough
with technology."
That speaks to a foundational weakness of liberal democracies.
They cannot update fast enough to keep up with technology. If
you let these technological gains for corporations that have
that have shareholders and are not beholden to any government,
if you let these technological gains compound over long enough
a long enough period of time, they will outpace the actual citizenry
of the United States, the government of the United States in
some
So, I think that's where it starts. I think that's >> Well,
that's why you have like anti-trust laws and regulation, but
I think like in the
I mean, I I agree about
I I'm very worried about this Congress and their ability to adapt
to the technological advancements that are happening with really
startling
>> to AI, I think that I think it that is a genuine concern.
>> And typically good but Congress has been a bit behind
the curve
when it comes to like massive
>> But they're getting further behind the curve. That's
the problem. >> or whatever. But he's like throwing the
baby out with the bathwater here cuz he's saying that
liberal democracy just fundamentally cannot handle the current
rate of like accelerate >> This current liberal democracy,
the way America's liberal democracy set up, no, it cannot.
The way that like the way that lobbying works, I understand that
lobbying isn't perfect or lobbying doesn't like guarantee votes,
but the way that lobbying works, all of these companies can essentially
guarantee that things will be locked up for far too long to do
anything about them, and it will have to be evident to every
single person essentially before change is made, and that's why
we're basically getting to
regulating like base Facebook as it was introduced at some point,
and we're still like 10 years behind. Every everything's so far
behind in terms of any regulation, right? It is moving too slow
to actually regulate or control anything. >> regulating
technology?
I mean may maybe he's right, but I mean
>> Um this guy actually said something probably correct,
supposedly fun. If a liberal democracy is slow to adapt technology,
it's because the people themselves are or don't care. Yes. Yes,
people can evaluate the threat that's coming. I think that is
part of it. They can only see the symptoms.
They they can't see like what's causing their worsening conditions
all the time. But it is the fact that essentially one, their
labors their labors being devalued, right? Educated, uneducated
workers alike are having their labor devalued. Either your labor
can be sent to somewhere where it's cheaper to pay for it, or
your labor can just be automated out in some way. And as that
continues, the most expensive labor in the world is only in the
United States. But as as that labor gets automated out or sent
away, the assets, the wealth of the people who own the capital
actually increases.
Right? So, you are actually increasing that wealth gap. So long
as that status quo remains,
nothing can be better for the people in
Something has to change with that.
And part of that is the technology, right? That there's no regulation
on technology that you could basically you come up with some
technology that avoids current regulations and you get to make
a whole a whole bunch of money before anybody ever regulates
you. Airbnb, that's Uber, that's a bunch of companies like this,
okay? And so, for as long as that continues, like
you're just you're in a cycle that you can't win, that you're
in like a downward spiral.
And something needs to shake that up, and I don't know exactly
what that is yet, but something needs to shake it up. >> So,
so this means what? So, you throw out liberal democracy for
Like, should we I mean like China?
>> Why does he have to Why does he have to straw man this?
>> Dude, it could be Hey, it could be like Here's Here's
like a totally hyperbolic
Um, you
nationalize the top three companies in America. You nationalize
like Amazon,
SpaceX or Tesla, both Elon companies, and like Apple.
You just nationalize them. That's not what I think should happen.
But let's say you just did that, right? You just nationalize
these companies. You just say, "We're actually
we're taking all of your assets. You give us all of your assets
right now."
I understand that that would have cataclysmic effects. I'm not
suggesting that, but it's like that would be somewhere you go
to be like, "Okay, these companies are getting really far
Somehow America needs to be more involved or more invested or
somehow beginning more more of a benefit from the massive wealth
generated." You know what I'm saying? I'm not I'm not saying
you actually do that, but somehow you need to do that gradually
and you need to be having that conversation. Like the Acapulco
stuff, when he started talking about that, I watched a bunch
of people come on and say that this guy's a socialist, this guy's
sweeping for socialist ideas, and we should kick him out of the
coalition. He can't be here
I watched people say that. I watched that Ukrainian person go
on and say that a wick, and I said,
she's a dumb bad word to use against women, okay? Well, actually
it was it was I don't want to make it sound like it was something
else. It wasn't that bad. So, a lot of people were saying that
[__] right? And I'm like, dude, that is that is the
lightest version of this. He is giving you the lightest version
that you could maybe start pivoting towards, and so many people
aggressively attacked him.
And so, I just don't know I don't know where you go from there,
cuz that's like the lightest version of dealing with this of
trying to Listen, if you can't control
where the technology is going, if you can't really regulate it
well, then at least the country should be invested in those companies,
no? We're going on to the next time stamp here. This is the next
one. Cuz you you aren't going to get blue no matter who. Blue
no matter who is them trying to break you into following whatever
they want. And I but at the same time, you should vote for Democrats
over Republicans, especially until the Republican Party has some
major schism
>> Can we hang on a minute? Did he just
Can we just listen to that? Everybody Listen, I I need everyone
to focus up. >> That's why you got to be overwhelming.
Cuz you you aren't going to get blue no matter who. Blue no matter
who is them trying to break you into following whatever they
want. >> Blue no Blue no matter who is them trying to break
you no matter what you want. Is that what he said? >> That
It's going to happen. That's why you got to be overwhelming.
Cuz you you aren't going to get blue no matter who. Blue no matter
who is them trying to break you into following whatever they
want. >> Blue no matter who is them trying to break you
into following whatever they want. Dot dot dot. And then he immediately
follows it up with >> And I but
Well, yeah, that is what you're doing, but I'm also saying what
they happen to want in this particular case in this one
in this midterm right now is to check Trump's power, so vote
Democrat. Do actually vote blue no matter who. Blue no matter
who. At the same time, you should vote for Democrats over
I'm basically saying that
it's not a sincere commitment to blue no matter who, it's a sincere
commitment to if you lose, you vote for us. Promise me right
now. They're not going to make any equivalent
Right? It was not blue no matter who in New York City. That was
not what it was. And you should expect that everywhere else,
too. The Republicans, especially until the Republican Party has
some major schism or change. Republicans are evil, but the blue
my good sir.
You have just stumbled upon the exceedingly simple logic of blue
no matter who.
>> Okay, so Kyle Kulinski, Hasan, all these people totally
within the blue no matter who you love them as Democrats
Cuz that's something that they've all Every single every single
time he's complained about this, they all say that same thing.
You should vote against Republicans. Republicans suck.
Hasan Even Hasan says it. As oppositional as Hasan gets, he even
says, "No, you should always vote to vote against Republicans."
You know what I'm saying?
He has literally stumbled into this that all of the rhetoric
from these people pushes you to vote blue no matter who. They
just don't say, "Obviously, I'm going to endorse this person."
Cuz they're annoyed that, you know, something happened or it
were a couple years out from an election. But every single element
of the rhetoric pushes people towards this. >> Why we say
blue no matter who?
Because the Republicans are genuinely that bad.
They are so
bad. We are so past the point where it's acceptable to elect
even a >> What's the evidence this guy's a grifter? Self-admitted.
Literally never happened a single time.
Bro, why do Why do these people all lie? [__] losers.
>> at any level of government. And it wasn't always like
that, to be honest with you. It wasn't always like that. The
stakes were not always this high
in terms of a Democrat winning a race versus a Republican winning.
>> It's not Okay, what should I say? It's not blue no matter
who. Again, the the
Cuomo thing is is what I I know will happen. And there is going
to be malfeasance in the Michigan election if Balsam were to
win that >> Republican party has >> They will say
you admitted to watching Fuentes. Okay, Pisco admits to watching
Fuentes. So Pisco is also a groper? Okay. Well, as long as Pisco
is also a groper, if Pisco is a groper, then I'm a groper, too,
I guess. You know? >> That is the logic of blue no matter
who. It's not we want to pound the electorate into submission
so they don't ask for more things. It's not that. It isn't that.
We can see Democrats at the state level all over the country
that are responding to the bases' desires. Like actually
a legislative agenda that is that responds to what they're asking
for. We are seeing that aggressively
happening in Virginia right now. And then we don't need to get
into it cuz we've gotten it into it so many times, but Joe Biden
himself moved to the left on so many issues after he won the
presidency.
>> When I said you guys would just go back to Joe Biden,
right? When I say that? Like you you you want to go back to Joe
Biden, and then Hutch goes, "I would never ever say that." And
then he's going to tell me how Joe Biden is the best president
ever. Which I even think Joe Biden was a consequential president.
But it's like you have to understand
Hutch thinks this is like a difference,
Hutch thinks so long as I endorse, I'm doing my job, and then
I'll talk about whatever. And it's like for a lot of other people,
the things you talk about, the whatever, is what matters, right?
The other stuff you do, the time you fill in on the sides, that's
that's like important. What are you talking about? What are you
dreaming about? What is your aspiration for America?
And the best I get out of Hutch and a lot of people is it's
and this is this is another thing that's seems to be inherent
to liberalism. You tell me what you're not. You're not
And you are not
Assad. And there's not a whole lot of time left over for what
you are. You're like, maybe we could make some we could pass
some bills that are slightly better. But it's like
I don't know.
At some point
the utopia thing almost speaks to some sort of nihilism to me,
right? When you constantly saying, "Oh, this is the nirvana fallacy."
It's like, yeah, but if you can't describe nirvana, what are
we even doing here? If you can't describe what you're moving
towards, what is happening?
I What do you What do you want? You should be able to describe
nirvana. You should never let nirvana cloud what is a valuable
contribution in the meantime. But as I just said with Spamburger,
I'm like, those all sound like great
But I don't What's nirvana for you?
Can you tell me what nirvana is?
>> So, we were pushing blue no matter who in 2020, but
then what did Biden do when he was elected? We We didn't tell
people to stop asking him for things. That's not what we're That's
not what it's about. It's just literally about the fact that
the Republican Party are so compromised right now. They're so
They're so bad right now
that we don't have a choice. And and In a lot of ways it
>> That's true. And you could say that, but that can't
be your primary message. Please, for the love of God, please,
for the love of God, please don't Like that should be sprinkled
in, but it can't be
It Dude, it can't. I
It's It's so cuz I think he
He sees my criticisms as like not accurate, and then he says
a whole bunch of things that I feel make my criticisms quite
accurate. Right? >> It makes things kind of easy. You can
focus on other things. Like you don't need to like
spend a great deal of time worrying about who should I vote for.
Like the answer to that is obvious. So, then the question becomes,
where do your efforts
And your efforts should go to like pressuring the politicians
that you helped elect
to to to to deliver on policies that you think would be good.
That's where your efforts should be going. I'm saying the opposite
of that. Don't don't just become complacent and just like take
whatever they get like push the Democrats to do more things.
Yes, help elect a Democrats and then push them to do more things
so that the outcomes are better. Yes, like this is
>> Is this not anti-liberal like in in of itself? Like
I I if I take Hutch's view to its extreme,
Democrats should basically go, we going to be better and then
it's like you have to vote Democrat or else the world explodes.
And then once they're in office, then you can be like, hey, you
guys should post you you guys should totally do this policy.
How do I know what I'm voting for? Where's the democracy there?
I
I don't know. Like what are we what are we doing, man?
Like this seems this seems very weird. Oh, try to try to push
them to do better policies when they actually get elected.
Like this is unfortunately this plays into Republicans are ahead
of this one. I swear I just watched something last night that
was talking about how Democrats want to, you know, pack the court,
but they're never going to run on it. If they win, they're going
to pack the court. And Hutch is basically saying, once you win,
push them for better policies than the what they're running on.
I don't know about that.
I got one more time stamp right here, right now.
This is the last one. And if you're not overwhelming, you do
have to swallow your pride a little bit and vote for their candidate
even if they were to you. You have to You have to vote Democrat
even if they were to you cuz it is consequential. The managed
decline is better than whatever the Republicans are offering,
okay? >> He He's conflating rat with just, you know, like
building a winning coalition. Like I I
>> No, I'm not. I'm literally not. >> And you should
just let me cook. This is little This is better because you're
going to say building a winning coalition. Actually, what we
were doing as Democrats when we decided to unify in a unified
manner, except for the person who could leech votes away from
Bernie when we all dropped out of the primary in a unified manner
to get behind Biden, that was just building a winning coalition.
No, to everybody who is behind Bernie was
So, just use their language. Don't code switch like this. Don't
do that.
He reacting to you again? Yeah, he is. Right? It's It's I'm going
to call cuz I'm trying to tell people that even if you get you
should still go vote. You should still go like actually support
this party. That you.
Until something changes. But, that's like one midterm and probably
not even the next presidential election. Well, maybe the next
presidential election, we'll see. But, it's it's like yeah.
Probably no matter what the next presidential election cuz I
don't know if you could ever trust, but
Yeah, you should think of it as You should just say it as I'm
trying to make it so that the rhetoric actually lands with these
people so they don't understand what they're signing up for.
>> Framing progressives
can't ever lose fairly. They can only be like Like that's the
only way that they lose,
>> They're Okay.
Obviously, if they don't think there's any malfeasance at all,
then they should just say we lost fair and square and move on.
But, they're going to see malfeasance and I'm saying even if
you see malfeasance, that should not bother you. That should
not That should not dissuade you from voting in favor of a Democratic
candidate.
he thinks that just normal politics
is like Like it's it's it's the it's the person who loses that
determines whether or not they were like the donors, the system,
you know, the media, like >> I got to interject there a
little. What did we blame for Kamala's loss? Was it
>> We don't re
>> Oh my god. Hutch is destroyed.
Hutch is destroyed.
>> Let me finish my what I what I'm about to say before
you launch into he man. >> You're totally Why can't you
just admit you got destroyed here? Nothing Hutch says fixes this.
Hutch just copes.
He knows he got destroyed here. Shut up. >> This Hutch
hatred is is is quite intense. >> Rekt. Hutch is rekt.
>> What did we blame for Kamala was lost? >> destroyed.
We love Soy Pill again. We've gone back and forth on Soy Pill
on this >> I mean Soy Pill is just I Listen, I love Soy
Pill. I love that fat ass of his, but [laughter] he's just wrong
about >> He's coping more. >> liberals spend so much
time. It's our favorite pastime. It's our favorite
>> You guys are going to react back to back, then you should
just come talk. I think he spent some time talking about why
he doesn't want to talk. I didn't bother going through any of
it cuz it's just like
it's honestly just he's going to believe other people instead
of any of the true facts. And eventually those those facts will
be deliberated.
And I know they all work out in my favor, so it's very easy.
>> When liberal candidates win big high-profile elections,
there are so many It's like Listen, it's not that like you do
have some of the cringe stuff that happens in the inverse
where I have seen prominent Democrats and prominent liberals
basically like blame everything on, you know, the far left. Like
that happens. I'm not saying that doesn't happen. But there's
also just a sh of people
that will spend months
like trashing the campaign and and unpacking dozens of a dozens
of reasons for why the campaign failed.
So there's just way more per capita,
a hun-
>> Okay, so is Hutch going to talk about what the actual
What What was the reason she failed? There's got to be at least
two or three. But what he's done so far is in reaction to everybody
laughing at the cope they all know is coming, he's coped a bunch
about how it's other people's problem, other people's fault.
>> hundred times more internal critique that happens within
liberal spaces when a liberal candidate lose loses
as opposed to the kind of the complete abject lack of internal
critique when the progressive candidates lose. >> Okay,
we loved him, then we hated him, now we love him again, all right?
Let's >> Don't rewrite history on this one. Were you on
the podcast when she >> He knows he's so caught. He knows
he's so caught and he's doing the exact same
I please I swear to God if he if Hutch does the same excuses
that they would do. Oh, what am I not supposed to say the truth?
>> The difference is is I could probably rattle off like
10 things that Kamala
that I think hurt her campaign
that is the fault of no one else. You know, there are things
that are very relevant like the fact that the macroeconomic trends
did not favor incumbent parties in 2024. That's
>> That's not in That's not something Kamala did wrong.
THAT'S LITERALLY NOT SOMETHING KAMALA did wrong.
I I could name some things she did wrong. Like something totally
out of her control happened. >> It's real. [laughter] That
happened.
There's the fact that she only had 107 days to campaign.
>> Something totally There's also the fact that there another
thing happened that was totally out of her control. There's no
way I could name a bunch of things Kamala did wrong. Like here's
something that was out of her control and another thing that
was out of her control. What?
What? Those aren't things she did wrong at all. >> Donald
Trump who had been campaigning basically for the prior 2 and
1/2 years. That that is like a That is like a very
>> Do you think Hutch will re-react to this cuz like this
is insane. This is just him coping obviously. These aren't even
things Kamala did wrong. I could name a bunch of things she [__]
up and then proceeds to name nothing she [__] up.
Things that were totally out of her
That's insane to be like no, I could totally name things she
did wrong and then cope.
>> strong headwind that she faced. Um the fact that she
inherited Biden's baggage. Biden was an unpopular incumbent president
and she >> That's He's three for three on things that Kamala
did not Kamala did not do these things. He's three for three.
Not a single thing has actually been something she [__]
up yet. >> vice president. She inherited that Like that's
relevant. But also she
very negligently
I would say
the alternative media space. So it's not that she ignored it
entirely. She did go on like a few podcasts, but I don't think
her and I don't think the Democratic Party broadly
really understood by 2024
just how important that space was. And so I think that that's
like a systemic problem within the Democratic Party and I would
argue that's like the number one problem. I think it gets over
simplified
when you say stuff like the big problem was she didn't go on
Rogan. Well, they know that was like an issue, but you know,
some of that was Rogan playing some weird games in the background
and you know, like not making any effort to actually host her.
It sounds like he >> I will say points for getting one.
I can name probably a bunch of things Bernie got wrong. I don't
really care all that much. On a superficial level, that that
stream he did where those two black women come up and take his
microphone away and he just sits quietly off on the side. Disastrous.
Absolutely disastrous for his campaign, okay? But we can probably
get into a bunch of other things, too. Anyway, I do want to just
laugh a little bit and I'm not going to I'm not going to hold
it totally against Hotch, okay?
But I do laugh that the thing you're supposed to learn from Kamala
not going to those spaces that it's important to get your voice
out in a bunch of different places and then he immediately campaigned
and was totally supportive of the third way stuff that was supposed
to be cutting Hasan [__] out of the Democrat coalition
saying nobody should talk to him. Like Like basically fundamentally
misunderstanding or or
failing to learn that lesson is the first thing he didn't follow
up. So his problem is actually sort of undercut by the fact that
he literally
doesn't get it. That he literally is making that same mistake.
But >> was actually actively >> Well, sorry. Was
making that mistake cuz I think he's rewritten history to be
like, "No, no, no. Nobody's ever wanted Hasan canceled." Which
is fake. >> working with Rogan to try to make an appearance
happen. And it sounds like he kind of wrapped them a little bit.
Um
But then also, I mean, like that that that's the big problem.
The fact that she, you know, felt too beholden to
I would say. The fact that she felt a loyalty to Biden. And so,
you know, she prioritized, I think, protecting Biden's legacy
the over
saying what needed to be said during an election year in order
to win. Like the fact that she she took such extraordinary effort
to, you know, go out of her way to uh not say that Biden did
anything wrong. Like, you know, like when she's asked, you know,
"What would you do differently?" And she just says like, "Oh,
nothing. It was basically just like perfect." You know, that's
not going to work with with an electorate that, you know, has
like a 39, 40%
>> What did she need to say? What are your criticisms of
Biden? What did Biden >> approval rating for Biden. You
know, there's a lot of people that were dissatisfied with Biden's
with Biden's perspective.
or Biden's performance with uh as president. Um
>> For the fact that she was more
on more kind of populist-y
framing in the beginning of her campaign. You know, she hit the
ground running. Like took her like 10 days to come up with a
policy page or something like that. Or maybe a little bit of
maybe it was a couple weeks, I'm not sure. But she, you know,
she she announces some of her policies. The first the very first
policy that she announces was like a anti-price gouging effort,
which was consequently, I think, like the most popular policy
that she proposed. But
>> Is that a mistake? I can't tell. I thought he was listing
off mistakes. She came up with populist policy, an anti-price
gouging >> some really bad influences to come into her
campaign and dissuade her from leaning into that policy, which
that was a really big mistake.
>> Oh, well, that is a No, that is a good
Uh she was I would say she was like quite stiff
>> in long-form settings.
>> Were those lefty Hold on, those influences that came
in, Hutch, were they lefties?
Were they like lefty influences that dissuaded her from that
anti-price gouging initiative? Or what kind of influences were
those people?
How did she shift that actually hurt her in the general? Cuz
it sounds like you're describing a shift that hurt her in the
general. Where did she shift towards? Who are those influences?
Be very important to know. >> So, that was like not necessarily
a weakness of her campaign, but more a weakness of her as a candidate.
So, like she did do some long-form content, but that you know,
I'm sympathetic because that's a lot of pressure. That's a lot
of stress. That's a lot of pressure for someone to you know,
I I don't think she expected to be handed the the the candidacy
in that kind of way.
Uh you know, and so like I but that's the game. That's the that's
what you need to be a politician. Like you have to be
you have to be ready for that kind of stress. And and it looked
like when she sat down and actually had these interviews, she
looked stressed. You know, you could feel that stress. And so
that I think didn't help her. And I I think that she'll probably
be better this time around because it's just completely different
circumstances. She can run a campaign on her on her own terms
and you know, and that and and and I don't think we're going
to see her as like quite as I think you're going to see a more
aggressive version of her. I think you're going to see a more
assertive version of her. She's going to be more comfortable
version >> I really hope not. Oh god. I really hope not.
I really hope not.
The VP was He said she wasn't ready to take over the campaign,
which I maybe we could give him the charity of saying that's
different than just being VP that she got to take it over as
president but wasn't ready to campaign.
That she didn't have a good idea of where she was shifting to,
I suppose. >> you're going to see a more >> But like
again, that's not even I don't even think that's a like a risk.
>> more aggressive version of her.
I think you're going to see a more assertive version of her.
I think you're going to see a more comfortable version of her
during this campaign. You could argue the fact that she was anointed.
You could argue that maybe that hurt her a little bit. That's
more on the margins. I tend to think that it was obvious that
if we had a miniature primary, she would have won. I think she
obviously would have won just because of name recognition alone.
And so you could say that Biden just sped up the process and
you know, like hey, let's just get to it and give her more time
to campaign. That's not like an easy situation. I don't know
what side I land on that. Like maybe it would have been better
to have like a symbolic
mini primary. Like maybe that would have given it more legitimacy.
>> Wait, is he saying open convention?
What do you mean symbolic?
What What does that even mean? Hold on.
Wait, unpack that. What the Did he just mean symbolic?
What What? Maybe there should have been a symbolic primary.
I don't know what the [__] he means right there.
That seems sketchy. >> Because that does seem to be like
a a vector of attack against her. Was this idea that she was
anointed and even though the Democratic Party voter base like
overwhelmingly approved of the fact that she got the nomination.
It was like a few days after she got the nomination like 95%
of the party supported her being the candidate. So it wasn't
an issue with like the Democratic voter base for the most part.
All Elite Memes with $20. The problem is lefty critiques don't
stick in this media environment while liberal critiques are blown
up and or distorted.
Lib shows do internal critique and debate. Lefty shows affirm
their biases. It's unilateral disarmament.
Well, I don't mean I don't want to do what they do. I think internal
critique is like I don't know if that's what you're suggesting,
but I don't want to do what they do. I think internal critique
is is very necessary for political movement.
>> Do you Wait, well, I mean, I'm not really a lefty. Do
lefties not do internal critiques of like how things how things
went badly? Does no lefty say Do lefties believe that Bernie
Sanders did nothing wrong in his campaign? Cuz I feel like I
feel like his mistakes or his like lack of of drive to win is
what lost him that campaign. Like I I don't even really think
it's close. I think it's like very obvious to me.
Is it Does he really believe that? Do people think that? That
Bernie did absolutely nothing wrong?
Most left Yeah, like basically there's a ton of I mean, I know
in 2016 that he could have maybe done something. There was like
a lot of appetite for change in
And he could have maybe done something. If he was willing to
go out and like really hit Hillary Clinton, but I do think he
held back a lot. I think he didn't go anywhere near as hard as
he could have, and he could have he could have been hitting all
this stuff about the DNC being corrupt all the time constantly.
And he left it to surrogates instead. And if he'd been doing
it himself, maybe he could have made it work. But he didn't want
to he didn't build up the cult of personality that Trump did
in the same way. Just wasn't the same thing. Yeah, he could have
also would have helped him a lot. I mean, I still don't think
like I he would have had to try to set it on fire to win in 2016.
Right? And probably that makes him a bad candidate if he's willing
to do that. So, I but I think it was like at least you get a
an idea of if it was possible. If he really tried, if he really
went like balls to the wall. In 2020, the same thing. He could
have been going very hard on people, and he just like
kind of was asleep at the wheel, so what can you do? In a 4 and
1/2 hour stream, he did about I don't know, 30 or 40 minutes
of actually tangibly listening, responding, and having any sort
of engagement.
And I guess that's, you know, what most people want, so cool.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. All right,
that's it for the Hutch stuff. We are on to whatever the next
thing is.